the corona virus pandemic is making us
go through some difficult times
having little to no social interaction
facing massive losses of life
and so much more now ironically
the most difficult thing we're facing is
working from home now i say
ironic because working from home was
like a dream to most people
but now that we've experienced it for a
few weeks most of us can agree it's
anything but a dream
on that note i'm rahul from simply learn
and welcome to the session
on how to work from home effectively i'd
like to welcome everyone joining us for
this session
today i'm going to give you some work
from home tips that can make the process
a whole lot simpler for you
firstly let's talk about how you can
pretend like you're still at work
number one you need to set up a morning
alarm
and wake up as you usually do now one of
the hardest things to do once you start
working from home
is to maintain the schedule that you
used to follow
number two take a shower before getting
started with work
now this step has two advantages one it
syncs you up with your normal schedule
and two it freshens you up
number three get dressed like you're
going to the office
now this step is more psychological in a
way
you're tricking your mind into thinking
it's still following the usual routine
if you think completely dressing up is
too much effort you could also just
dress up your top half
that way you can look presentable in the
mini zoom calls or hangout meets
that you're part of number four
don't start work immediately now this
one ties back to all the points i
mentioned earlier
without the routine it's possible that
over the span of the day
you could lose interest in work and end
up not being productive at
all number five
communicate expectations with everyone
at home now
most of us have families with us at home
it's
really important for them to know that
even though you're at home
you're working from home
number six put your phone in another
room or on silent mode
now this one's self-explanatory i don't
have to explain why this is
really important number seven
and this one's probably the most
important follow
your work routine like nothing's changed
so on a normal day if you start off by
checking your email
i would suggest you do the same from
home as well
now let's talk about your workspace
you need to create a workspace for
yourself at home
a place where you can get your work done
without any distractions
number two in this workspace you need to
make sure
only work is done and nothing else
number three you'll also need to avoid
having food in the area
by physically going to another place to
have food
you're subconsciously cementing the
thought that the workplace is for work
only number four make sure the workspace
is comfortable this makes sure that
you're not fed up with the place after
sitting there for
long periods of time as you know all
work and no play makes jack a dull boy
so let's talk about taking a break
number one make sure you have at least a
10 minute break for yourself
every two hours now it's very easy to
get lost in work and forget to give
yourself some rest
remind yourself to take a break every
now and then to ensure that you are
refreshed
number two spend some time watching
stuff on youtube be it songs
videos of kittens or puppies trailers
anything that catches your fancy
number three spend some time on social
media get in touch with friends through
video call and so on
number four take some time off for food
breakfast
or lunch take a coffee or tea break as
well
number five communicate with some real
people at home
it's important that you have some real
interaction with people during this
period of time
talk to your family check in on them get
the conversation going
and finally the end of day you need to
log off
and stay logged off now once you're done
try to make sure you switch off from
work for the day
unless there's an emergency that is
and with that we've reached the end of
the session we hope you guys found this
informative
and helpful don't forget to subscribe
sanitize
and stay safe thank you for watching and
stay tuned for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here